♪♪
>>> THESE DAYS WHEN I SIT DOWN
TO WATCH A MOVIE, I CAN FIND
JUST ABOUT ANYTHING IN THE
WORLD.
BUT NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, THERE'S
ONLY ONE KIND OF MOVIE I'M
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR.
♪ AND THAT'S A ♪
♪ SHORT-ASS MOVIE
A REALLY SHORT MOVIE
LIKE AT MOST AN HOUR 40 ♪
♪ GIVE ME THAT
SHORT ASS MOVIE
A SHORT-ASS MOVIE ♪
♪ A REALLY SHORT MOVIE
'CAUSE YOU KNOW
I AIN'T GONNA SIT HERE ♪
♪ AND WATCH NO LONG-ASS MOVIE
FOUND A FLICK
ABOUT TO PICK IT ♪
♪ BUT RIGHT BEFORE
I CLICK IT
I LOOK DOWN ♪
♪ RIGHT BELOW THE LINE
AND THAT'S WHEN I SEE
THE RUN TIME ♪
♪ 3 HOURS 47 MINUTES
BRO YOU MUST BE CRAZY
NO THANKS ♪
♪ I'M GONNA WATCH
A SHORT-ASS MOVIE
LIKE DRIVING MISS DAISY ♪
♪ I'M NOT PUSHIN' P
UNLESS IT'S
UNDER TWO HOURS ♪
♪ LIKE LION KING
OR BAD MOMS
OR ALL THREE AUSTIN POWERS ♪
♪ I HEARD THE BATMAN
WAS GREAT
SO I WENT TO A THEATER ♪
♪ AND SAW IT
I PISSED MY PANTS TWICE
THAT [ BLEEP ] WAS LONGER ♪
♪ THAN THE HOBBIT
GIVE ME THAT
SHORT-ASS MOVIE ♪
♪ A 90-MINUTE MOVIE
LIKE LIAR LIAR
EVIL DEAD ♪
♪ ERASERHEAD
A SHORT-ASS MOVIE
A REALLY SHORT MOVIE ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I'M A SIMPLE MAN
WITH NO ATTENTION SPAN
GIVE ME THAT ♪
♪ SHORT-ASS MOVIE
LIKE BAMBI
GOT TO BE TINY BUT GOOD ♪
♪ LIKE SHRIMP SCAMPI
AND WHEN IT'S MOVIE NIGHT
YOU WON'T BE GETTING
ANY YESES ♪
♪ IF YOU ROLL UP
TO THE CRIB
WITH ONE OF THEM ♪
♪ DOUBLE VHSs ♪
>> WHY DOES THIS MOVIE LOOK LIKE
A BOOK?
>> BYE-BYE.
♪ I ALWAYS KEEP IT A HUNNID ♪
♪ KEEP THAT RUNNING TIME
UNDER 100
IF MY ASS STUCK ON ♪
♪ THE COUCH FOR MORE
THAN TWO HOURS
IT CAUSES ME DISCOMFORT ♪
♪ WE TRIED TO WATCH
THE MOVIE HEAT
WHEN WE WAS HANGING ♪
♪ AT MY HOUSE
BUT BARELY 20 MINUTES IN
MY BOYS WERE DROOLING ♪
♪ ON THE COUCH ♪
>> THE ONLY ONE NOT SLEEPING IS
THE WEIRD GUY WHO PICKED THE
MOVIE.
>> I STAND BY MY CHOICE.
♪ GIVE ME THAT ♪
♪ SHORT-ASS MOVIE
A REALLY SHORT MOVIE
LIKE ENCINO MAN ♪
♪ YES PLEASE
OR GOOD TIME
BY THE SAFDIES ♪
♪ A SHORT-ASS MOVIE
A REALLY SHORT MOVIE
IF IT'S LONG ♪
♪ MY EYES GET GLASSY
NOW TELL THEM HOW IT IS
DIRT NASTY ♪
♪ YO IT'S YOUR BOY DIRT
IF YOU LIKE SHORT MOVIES
I'VE GOT NINE GREAT ONES ♪
♪ JUST WAITING
FOR YOU
THERE'S ♪
♪ ERNEST GOES TO CAMP
AND ERNEST SAVES CHRISTMAS
AND ERNEST GOES TO JAIL ♪
♪ AND ERNEST SCARED STUPID
THERE'S
ERNEST GOES TO SCHOOL ♪
♪ THAT'S ONLY 89 MINUTES
AND SLAM DUNK ERNEST
THAT ONE'S ♪
♪ GOT KAREEM IN IT
THERE'S ERNEST IN THE ARMY
MADE ME WANT TO ♪
♪ JOIN THE SERVICE
AND ERNEST GOES TO AFRICA
THAT POSTER ♪
♪ MAKES ME NERVOUS
BUT THE GREATEST
THING OF ALL ♪
♪ A TRUE THING OF BEAUTY
IS THE THREE-MINUTE SHORT
BEFORE EVERY PIXAR MOVIE ♪
>> IT'S SO SAD.
>> SO THINK ABOUT THIS.
"SEX AND THE CITY 2" WAS 2 HOURS
AND 26 MINUTES LONG.
TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE, THE
MOVIE "JURASSIC PARK" WAS TWO
HOURS AND SEVEN MINUTES LONG.
THAT WAS A MOVIE THAT TOLD THE
HISTORY OF DINOSAURS, HOW DNA
WORKS AND EXPLAINED THE SCIENCE
OF BRINGING DINOSAURS BACK TO
LIFE.
AND "SEX AND THE CITY 2," YOU
KNOW, WHICH WAS A MOVIE ABOUT
FOUR WOMEN WE ALREADY KNEW, WAS
20 MINUTES LONGER.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S BAD OR
ANYTHING.
I'M JUST SAYING, THAT'S SOME
CRAZY [ BLEEP ] RIGHT?
>> HOW LONG WAS "THE KING OF
STATEN ISLAND?"
>> IT WAS LIKE 2 HOURS AND
17 MINUTES.
BUT WE NEEDED -- WE NEEDED ALL
THOSE MINUTES.
♪ GIVE ME A SHORT-ASS MOVIE ♪
♪ A REALLY SHORT MOVIE
GIVE ME A SHORT-ASS MOVIE
A REALLY SHORT MOVIE ♪
♪ EVERY NIGHT ♪